On any given day,
a substantial proportion of the business
news is about strategy beyond markets.
That makes it timely, topical,
interesting, and engaging.
[MUSIC]
>> This program is about interactions with
the public, it's about interactions with
government's, it's about interactions
with legal and regulatory authorities,
all of which can have a profound effect on
a firm's profitability in the marketplace.
>> It's evidence-based,
deep structural thinking that
literally does not exist anywhere else,
at any other school.
That's what's really exciting about it.
>> The program is intended
to equip today's leaders and
tomorrow's future leaders with tools that
they can implement on the day they return
to their organization.
>> New ideas, new tools, different ways of
thinking, and maybe employing new tactics,
broader strategies in
the non-market-oriented realm.
But more importantly than that,
I'm developing a confidence around
the importance of these sorts of things.
>> You can't sort a come up
with your business plan and
then come up with your plan for
dealing with governments and the public.
You need to think of those
two things at the same time.
>> It just creates a broadening of our
traditional points of view that we
otherwise wouldn't have had.
>> How an organization handles a crisis
can have short-term and long-term impact
on an organization's reputation and
ability to participate in the marketplace.
>> And if you can do a better job dealing
with those things than your competitors
do, that's really a powerful foundation
for success in the marketplace.
>> I feel more prepared and effective
as I return to Google to advance policy
issues on the ground, as I know what
to say, when to say, and how to say it.
>> Imagine you're a deep sea diver diving
in the dark and someone comes along and
offers you an oxygen tank, a flashlight,
and a grid map of the bottom of the ocean.
You liked diving, but
now you have an extraordinary opportunity
to think about the world, and
understand where you are and
what your choices are,
in a very different way.
>> Participants in the program will walk
away with a set of concrete tools for
how to interact and
how to start strategically understand
what's going on with interest groups,
with activists, with governments, and with
the courts and regulatory authorities.
Ways of conceptualizing what
those other folks are doing, and
how to deal with them strategically.
[MUSIC]